les ministres de la défense de l'otan se
retrouvent aujourd'hui à bruxelles pour
une réunion consacrée aux menaces de
sécurité on en parle avec vous alexis
valasse bonjour ancien conseiller
politique
politique de l'otan pardon et l'union
européenne m par ailleurs deux
conférences à sciences po strasbourg
première question les questions de
sécurité les questions de menaces
vis-à-vis de la russie concrètement ça
va ça va reposer sur quoi ces échanges
du jour
alors attendez jusqu'à maintenant je ne
vois pas de menace de l'otan ou de
l'union européenne contre la russie pour
en revenir à la réunion d'aujourd'hui il
s'agit des ministres de la défense et
quand on convoque les ministres de la
défense en général c'est pas pour
prendre des décisions importantes et
sensible politiquement je pense qu'il
s'agit d'évaluer des options militaires
d'une part le renforcement actuel de ce
qu'on appelle le flanc est de l'alliance
atlantique et d'autre part des options
militaires qui vont commencer à être
travaillés en vue du sommet de l'otan de
juin prochain à madrid où il a il s'agit
de renforcer beaucoup de manière
beaucoup plus permanente le dispositif
de l'otan sur son cul en l'air
les points de les prendre des changes
aujourd'hui lors de ce prochain
sommet on nous dit éviter l' escalade on
l'a vu encore ce week-end vous évoqué
l'absence de menace certains à à l'est
de l'union européenne se sentent
directement menacés on entendu des
polonais des moldaves des roumains aussi
convaincu que les russes allaient aller
au delà de la frontière ukrainienne
et je pense qu'on peut être convaincus
de rien maintenant il ya un jeu
diplomatique il ya des divergences entre
les états membres au sein de l'otan
comme de l'union européenne comme le
mécanisme décisionnel et à l'unanimité
c'est toujours le plus petit commun
dénominateur qui qui s'imposera je crois
que l'otan essaie de faire le maximum en
faveur de l'ukraine tout en évitant
l'escaladé en main en maintenant une
dissuasion forte vis-à-vis de la russie
à l'endroit de la russie pour qui aucune
attaque contre un des états membres
l'un des enjeux aussi sera sûrement de
mobiliser davantage contre la russie on
évoquait ce matin avec ariel charrier
les précédents échanges au sein de
l'otan on parlait beaucoup de la chine
la russie serré imposé en première ligne
en quelques semaines seulement
oui exactement et je crois que tout le
monde comprend que ce qui est en jeu a -
vraiment mais c'est pas le plus probable
que cette parenthèse se referme
rapidement que la russie retire
complètement ses troupes mais encore il
resterait le problème de l'actrims et
on comprend qu'on risque l'a de rentrer
dans une nouvelle organisation du monde
avec le risque d'une bipolarité très
conflictuels entre d'un côté le monde et
l'occident et de l'autre un espèce de
duo
sino russe et c'est vrai que dans la
déclaration sino-russe du 4 février que
les explications de vote de
l'ambassadeur chinois aux nations unies
on craint vraiment un espèce de soutien
implicite de la chine
sur les positions russes éventuellement
en échange d'un donnant donnant sur
taïwan plus tard et ça c'est très près
où on est entreposé les bases
du nouveau monde si on peut s'exprimer
ainsi on apprend à l'instant que le
chancelier allemand la chose va recevoir
demain le secrétaire général yann
sundberg
il ya de vraies discussions concrètes
sérieuses aujourd'hui
il ya de vraies discussions alors pour
ce qui est de l'otan sur effectivement
la manière d'être le plus efficace
possible dans le soutien à l'ukraine et
puis dans une réorganisation à long
terme de l'otan basées sur un effort
supplémentaire des états membres des 30
états membres de l'otan pour avoir une
résilience plus forte en cas de menace
une question l'otan la vue et est
régulièrement sollicité par le président
volodymyr zelensky qui on le sent bien
dans sa danse art et oreilles dans ces
mots semblent s'être ravisé il a encore
dit hier l'ukraine n'intégrera pas
l'otan on sent bien là la grande
désillusion des ukrainiens aujourd'hui
quels sont ses moyens ses champs
d'action
à l'otan aujourd'hui je crois que le
président ukrainien avait un double but
d'abord essayé d'impliquer l'otan on
peut le comprendre mais vous avez aussi
très clairement vu que l'otan veut
maintenir un un seuil claire de
belligérance continuer à montrer d'un
point de vue politique c'est une
alliance défensive et dont il s'agit pas
de s'impliquer dans un conflit qui
pourrait amener une conflagration
mondiale et puis le second but de
l'ukraine c'est évidemment puisque à
force d'être amputé agressé par la
russie l'ukraine c'est beaucoup plus
occidentalisé elle l'était auparavant là
c'est évidemment de se rapprocher avec
l'union européenne et otan et là je
crois qu'il ya un but tactique et le
président ukrainien a raison de manière
dilatoire on n'a rien à perdre à dire
aujourd'hui qu'on est prêt à envisager
une certaine un certain type de
neutralité pour l'ukraine et et ce
d'autant que l'otan réalité
n'envisageait pas à court terme de à
court terme d'intégrer l'ukraine et pour
finir vous savez je pense que à plus
long terme juridiquement vous pourrez
toujours changer d'avis il ya toujours
le principe du changement fondamental de
circonstance et politiquement si
vraiment la majorité des ukrainiens
vue-là rattachement à l'otan dans 5 7 ou
10 ans et bien un engagement pris
aujourd'hui pourrait être révisée donc
le jeu du président ukrainien s'est
évidemment d'envisager aujourd'hui de
une neutralité de l'ukraine
on a vu que cette cette guerre en
seulement trois semaines avait avait
redonné de l'élan à l'otan en tant
qu'organisation on a vu aussi qu'elle
avait fait progresser l'union européenne
fait un bond de presque 20 ans dans les
prises de décision en tout cas dans des
positions affichées notamment sur la
question de l'europe de la défense
quelles sont aujourd'hui les les moyens
d'action des vingt-sept indépendamment
de l'otan
d'abord je pense que l'otan est fait
pour des crises graves donc
effectivement on redécouvre ses c'est
cet axe ont intérêt lorsqu'on est face à
une menace du type de celle que peut
faire peser la fédération de russie du
côté de l'union européenne je crois
d'abord qu'on met estime ce qu'a déjà
accompli l'union européenne je vous
rappelle que depuis que l'union
européenne lance des opérations
militaires à des missions civiles
c'est-à-dire en 2003 il n'y a aucune
autre organisation internationale qui
est lancé autant d'opérations militaires
est une mission civile que l'union
européenne maintenant ce qui concerne la
défense du territoire européen l'a
évidemment il ya une articulation
affaire avec l'otan on sort du débat
idéologique parce qu'on est vraiment là
dans un problème de sécurité réelle donc
on voit de moins en moins deux de ces
beaux penseurs qui nous parlaient en
termes exclusiviste soit vous choisissez
l'otan ait lieu on voit qu'on conçoit
les deux ensemble et effectivement
l'union européenne elle se construit en
essayant de bâtir une autonomie
stratégique mais en complémentarité avec
l'otan et c'est ce qui se passe dans
cette crise là merci beaucoup alexi
bales instant d'avoir été notre 1